fait manga japonais ça veut dire dessin
frivole et c'est exactement ce que je
pense qu'un manga doit être c'est que ça
doit être fou en fait ça doit être animé
dynamique ça doit sortir de partout fait
mal dessinée beaucoup quand elle était
petite elle m'a transféré cette passion
du dessin
pour moi le manga c'est vraiment la
formule type de création quoi c'est à
dire que tout ce que tu vois dans ta
tête tu peux quasiment le mettre en
application sur ta feuille avec
uniquement justement une feuille et un
crayon donc la france est le deuxième
plus grand marché au monde pour les
mangas et c'est normal parce que nous
les français on a besoin de rêver et
quoi de mieux pour rêver que les mangas
je dirais que la différence entre un
manga japonais est un manga fait en
france elle se fait sur le rythme de
parution en fait comme au japon le manga
c'est vraiment une industrie incroyable
chaque dessinateur chaque auteur est
entouré de d'assistant desdites à à
plein temps donc ils produisent un
chapitre par semaine ce qui leur permet
de compiler un tome tous les deux mois
et demi en france on n'a pas du tout la
même industrie le même encadrement donc
du coup un auteur français lorsqu'ils se
donnent vraiment il sort deux temps par
an du coup comme tu sors quand sommes
tous les six mois tu es obligé de finir
chaque tome sur un énorme suspense était
obligé aussi de compresser le tome pour
qu'ils aient beaucoup de contenu pour
que le lecteur en est pour son attente
euros
[Musique]
le rythme d'un manga et surtout dictée
par les pages de droite
en fait quand vous lisez un manga tous
les suspenses sont faits est calculé
pour être racontée en bas d'une page de
gauche afin que lorsque vous tournez la
page prime une grosse révélation sur la
page de droite c'est pour éviter de
spoiler le lecteur pour pas que
lorsqu'ils lisent ces deux pages sommeil
à gauche déjà remarqué ce qui allait se
passer plus tard c'est pour ça qu'on met
tout des révélations sur des pages de
droite
[Musique]
faites attention aux détails comme un
microscope étudier chaque détail du
domaine que vous voulez maîtrisé et
après dix ans et après dix ans on dit
que pour devenir maître de quelque chose
il faut dix mille heures de travail
je suis convaincu que vous créerez
d'excellentes choses